as ukrainians suffer incomprehensible
loss during the war with russia there
are many in this country who are also
feeling the scars of the conflict about
350 000 ukrainian-born immigrants live
right here in the united states and two
of them are sharing their stories and
their photos with us arena is a teacher
from a small town in central ukraine she
didn't want to say the name for fear of
what might happen to her family there
and olesia came to the united states in
the 1990s as a student from kiev they
told us about the guilt they feel
because they are safe from the war and
their hopes for life once the fighting
is over
my name is irina ormond
and originally i am from ukraine
everybody who i know and love in ukraine
i'm the only one here i wake up and
every time i my first thing what i do i
run to the phone
just make sure that they're okay
[Music]
it's really upsetting because i have
millions of thoughts in my head maybe
they're in in the shelter maybe
something happened to them
my name is alessia govern and i'm
originally from cave ukraine when i
think about my current experience it's
almost like having a death in your
family every single day i think there's
also guilt that i'm not there that i
cannot physically defend my country i'm
very
fortunate to be in this country at this
moment
though i feel guilty every day about
that my brother he's actually an engine
driver he is the one who is driving the
trains from eastern ukraine to western
ukraine bringing
refugees it's not enough to take
everybody and some people couldn't get
in and it's heartbreaking
my aunt doesn't have water she doesn't
have electricity it brings it very close
to home for me i grew up in ukraine but
it was part of the soviet union it was a
happy childhood as my grandparents on
mother's side had a wonderful house with
a cherry and apple trees around it
i hope it won't be bombed that's
what i hope for and those beautiful
trees won't be burnt
and
it's um
it's emotional you know
it's very close to home
[Music]
when i hear the news
i feel like
almost a physical
sense of being there
and
and
you know that that that makes it very
very difficult but
cave is absolutely gorgeous
when i think of cave i think of golden
domes of so many churches it is it is
peaceful
i try to become on the surface and
restrain my emotions so sometimes it's
impossible especially when you talk to
people who still think that putin has a
right to do what he's doing the
ukrainians are like a beehive
we are peaceful bees you know we mind
our own business we work for the
collective good but if somebody attacks
the beehive we all unite we know that
there is a big big work is ahead of us
but we are not afraid of it
we would like to build a new ukraine my
dad passed away um slightly more than a
year ago he believed that
ukraine was
kind of like a phoenix bird that you
know it will always rise from the ashes
and it has always risen from the ashes
well i hope she's right what we do know
about the ukrainian people they're very
strong and very proud yeah of their
country rising from the ashes i think
millions of people not just ukrainians
not just people of ukrainian descent in
the united states but all around the
world would like to see that happen and
i like when she says that kiev is a very
beautiful place i think that's good to
know because for us when we look at it
for many of us the only images we now
know are bombed out and just destroyed
and decimated yeah very nice
in many ways looks like paris or any
other major european capital city i have
heard that